I've got plenty of quirks I go to an  office early in the morning and early in  the morning is is really good writing  time I take anywhere between six to  eight showers a day because I'm not I'm  not exaggerating I'm not exaggerating  I'm not a germaphobe there's nothing to  do with germs it's all about a fresh  start okay I was writing I was writing  was not going well I'm writing badly  start again take a shower put on  different clothes and you'll feel  refreshed and and start again is it  harder sober is it better or sober I  don't care if it's harder or better  sober I I should be dead seven times by  now and I'm I'm so glad I'm not yeah  maybe  um it would be easier to write with coke  maybe I'd write better with coke but I'm  and there's writing well is so important  to me that there's no advantage I  wouldn't give myself except that